ben alors qu'au départ on sait jamais je
n'ai pas d'oreillette je ne sais pas où
est serré les musulmans il est entre ici
et sa loge
donc je dois commencer l'émission je ne
sais pas par quoi parce que je découvre
l'émission c'est un arrêt il a fait un
arrêt au stand
[Applaudissements]
les
en salles ce mercredi 5 février il y a
ça y est il est arrivé ducobu 3
elie semoun est avec no mercy monde et
dida et 10 semoun n'est pas lui c'est
monsieur latouche c'est ça silence cyril
hanouna
en quelle année tu as eu lieu la prise
de la bastille monsieur ducobu 1900
waris en 1789 pas vous avez triché c'est
clair
quel animal a pour nom latin firn à
meaux karan
on va réfléchir
le budget le requin marteau
sur géographie pour cyril à quel massif
montagneux situé dans le sud ouest de
l'allemagne dans le land de bade
wurtenberg sais pas ce qui se passe
faites attention si la réponse je pense
que c'est la forêt noire
quel pays à organiser la coupe du monde
de football de 1938 quelques lignes
[Applaudissements]
je vais dire le langage boudjerada
appelait il ya très longtemps pour venir
me touche pas à mon poste et moi
effectivement j'avais de lego je parle
de ma foi ça passe ça pète de lego j'ai
dit ah j'avais dit à des actions à des
pubs à la pression moi je veux bien bien
sûr la chaîne mais certainement pas en
tant que chroniqueur je vais pas en plus
montrer mon cul et mettre une perruque
série là dessus qu'ils ont été
ouvertement en guerre parce que nous
donner des rendez-vous alors on a fait
chaud c'est l'époque où j'étais ans et
nouvelle star mais il savait très bien
que j'attendais comac ont donc pour pour
nos têtes et je pense que c'est peu
classe et pas heroes n'est pas à 21h15
parce qu'il rendait à 21h30 de 35-40 il
devenait que ferais je détestais series
avait une place prédominante
il n'avait pas bien compris à l'époque
je manquais un peu de finesse et
maintenant on peut le dire mais nos amis
qu on est très amis
merci yacine d'être là sa maman yacine
120 super merci de me recevoir et cyril
est un animal ce serait ça serait quoi
bon moi c'est une force et un sur icap
vous sortez tous d'un coup donc voilà
c'est quelque chose qu'un autre malade
féerique
le [ __ ]
c'est richard anconina qui
[Applaudissements]
richard anconina qui étaient avec nous
c'est un grand sportif roger d'un vélo
donc je vais vous dire je vous posais
des questions sur richard anconina
richard est un sportif qui a initié
patrick bruel au tennis bruno solo la
pétanque
booba à la boxe thaï ou gad elmaleh au
vélo garde aux vélos dire gad elmaleh au
vélo moi j'aurais dit malade et richard
tu oublies tout bien donnée importante
quoi bats toi j'étais initiée au tennis
s'était formée non je sais bien qu'il
faut remonter alors très bien a bien sûr
imaginons je t'ai vu tu vas aller au
tennis l'élève a dépassé le maître après
nous allons y est perdu et joubert à
méru 15 là un jeu combien
laissez moi voire harcèlements piratage
et dérapages faut-il avoir peur
d'internet merci à rabat des bois dé
travail qui mentionnait merci beaucoup
est ce qu'on peut avoir les adresses
mail de certains est-ce qu'on peut
rentrer dans les mails de certaines
personnes ou par exemple est piraté leur
compte mail c'est facile ça peut pirater
des adresses email on peut pirater des
serveurs des sites internet en fait à
partir du moment de se connecter à
internet c'est vulnérable même votre
monde connecté cyril qui vous indique je
sais pas vous votre performance de coeur
par exemple ça ça peut être piraté
si je vous envoie un lien par exemple
sur lequel j'essaye de fiche est de
récupérer derrière vous vous adresse
email et vos mots de passe et que vous
cliquez sur ce lien vous êtes infectés
donc en fait il faut avoir une
conscience numérique de façon à pouvoir
réaliser qu internet bah c'est pas tout
rose et qu'il ya des gens qui vous
veulent du mal et que vos données
personnelles vous devez en tout cas les
protéger la numérisation de la société
c'est réel aujourd'hui on est
conditionné à penser qu'un smic ou de
smic ou 3 smic c'est beaucoup alors
qu'en réalité avec internet vous pouvez
très bien être votre propre maître
financiers quand vous pouvez avoir votre
votre livre
tu chéris et avec el naga c'est la
première fois que vous
nasa quand je suis arrivé j'ai cru c'est
un personnage de max linder à l'ailé
gauche c'est le titre du moment et je me
suis amusé à faire un petit truc puisque
j'ai imaginé les chroniqueurs avec
quelques kilos en plus à isa
[Rires]
des noms les bâtards l'exercice un
dividende et que ce que par devant vous
êtes un amour mais quand vous êtes avec
votre ami matthieu delormeau
vous êtes en mode catherine et liliane
faut dire qu'il est une a failli tuer
relation villes saccagées renault nissan
c'est pas les micros on n'est plus bien
dans sa chute
on est privilégié quand on est
ravissante
ben oui avait répété les mêmes phrases
sur slam français voit l'accueil de cet
[Musique]
événement méchant
[Applaudissements]